[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna back here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment of our weekly anime news
cast the links are in the description
recommendations goal in the comment as
always this is a weekly newscast that we
do here on the channel to catch you up
on all the latest anime and manga news
and before we get started I want to
thank everybody who helped get the anime
out for a Facebook page to over 500
likes thank you so much and if you do
use Facebook you can follow us there you
can like our Facebook page for all the
latest updates because you know that
YouTube notifications tend to screw up
quite frequently last week at Anime Expo
studio trigger announced three new anime
projects including darling in the Frank
xx grid Monde and Pro Merrick
now pro Marais or premier I'm not sure
which is the correct pronunciation yet
is going to be a collaboration between
trigger and ex flag and I am really
excited about this one this is
definitely the one that I'm most excited
about because the creators have stated
that this one is going to be inspired
directly influenced by Gurren Lagann and
kill a kill which are some of my
favorite anime of all time the director
of this project Hiroyuki mi she worked
in some capacity on Neon Genesis
Evangelion fully cooley good and logon
and kill a kill which are all in like my
top 15 anime of all time so I'm really
excited for this project and let me know
if you're excited down below also this
past week my hero academia came back for
the second part of its second season and
in this latest episode we got to see a
fewer students training with a whole
bunch of different heroes and actually I
thought it was great to see some of
these heroes animated in the anime
outside of the black-and-white format or
the manga especially my girl wobba me
who looks even better in color the snake
hero baby if you are interested in
learning more about all the pro heroes
last Friday we uploaded a brand new my
hero academia video where we explain all
the known pro heroes in the show so be
sure to check that out link in the
description and the next episode is set
to focus on the League of villains and
shigaraki so I'm really looking forward
to that
misty connects ER released a short
teaser this week for the second episode
of his independent animation project
Krone Exia and the eight seals now even
though this was only a short teaser you
could tell right away that the quality
of the animation was way better than the
first episode which I was really happy
to see and after the video mists he
actually said that he's been looking at
all the feedback they've been receiving
about the first episode and they've been
actively working on improving the show
for the next episode now personally I
definitely respect misty for doing this
he could have easily said hey I'm a
successful youtuber I don't need to
listen to anybody I'm going to do what I
want or he could have said I'm a
successful youtuber I'm going to do what
works on my channel I'm going to abandon
this project it's way too time-consuming
but instead he said he is listening to
the feedback he is doing his best to
improve the project based on the
constructive feedback he received and I
think he needs to be commended for that
if you want to check out the teaser and
see for yourself the link is in the
description
Aki teareth released a video this week
about anime that are hugely popular in
Japan but never really caught on in most
Western countries and I thought that
this was a really interesting video I
also really appreciated her epic
pronunciation of Doraemon I'm glad that
I've been able to catch up on some of
Aki's videos lately because she has been
spending a lot of time in Japan and so
she's been making content telling anime
fans outside of Japan what Japan is
really like and I think that this is
really important for us anime fans to
know because anime is so immersed within
the unique Japanese cultural and
historical context I would definitely
recommend checking out this video and
other videos in which she talks about
what Japan is really like also some of
you seem to be under the impression that
I didn't talk about the fooly cooly
season 2 & 3 trailer last week but I
most certainly did be sure to check out
last week's weekly anime news cast the
leading story was attack on Titan season
3 being scheduled for spring of 2018
however after that I definitely talked
about fooly cooly as you guys know I
love the anime I can't wait for seasons
two and three so be sure to check that
out also this week that anime snob
everyone's favorite anime YouTube
villain apparently had his YouTube
channel terminated now what seems to
have happened is that someone reported
his walkthroughs for some anime at
okay games saying that these videos were
inappropriate and then YouTube ended up
terminating his channel because of it
now I don't know I thought that these
videos were censored anyway so I don't
know if this was the right decision by
YouTube however I definitely hope that
he ends up getting his channel back
because whether you agree with them or
not we can always choose not to watch
his videos if we don't agree with them
but I think that everyone deserves the
right to you know say what they want to
say and have a platform and exercise
their free speech so I definitely hope
he settles this soon in the meantime he
is going to be posting videos to vid me
so I will leave the link to that in the
description and as I said whether you
love him or hate him
no one deserves to have their videos
taken off YouTube and their channel
terminated just for being a snob and my
favorite a MV for this week is a faith
Apocrypha a MV called warrior by Amol
anime or mo anime I'm not sure which one
this MV is really well done especially
when we consider the fact that only two
episodes of the anime are out so far I
like the song and how it went with the
imagery it was just a great job overall
now personally I've seen the first two
episodes of fate Apocrypha and I have
mixed feelings but I will talk more
about that on this week's episode of
Rand cafe and that is a podcast that we
do live here on this channel every
Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
we talk about all sorts of anime topics
and this week we're going to be talking
about the summer 2017 anime and our
first impressions of some of these anime
and if you can be sure to join us this
Thursday and every Thursday at 5 p.m.
Eastern Standard Time right here live at
anime uproar and before we go I want to
give a quick shout out to all our
patrons who have been supporting the
channel thank you guys so much your
support helps make all these videos
possible and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]